Hey everybody. Hi. Thanks for having
me. Do you guys have a good lunch? Yeah,
me too. I'm telling you I want to work
here cause that lunch was awesome. Um,
I don't make anything near that.
Anyways,
my name is Matthew Reinhardt
and I make poppop books.
Some people call me a paper engineer's,
some people call me.
I'm a children's book illustrator.
I'm,
I like to think of myself as
all those things and many more.
And today I'm going to show you a little
bit about, you know, how I do what I do.
I'm also going to make a pop up here
and show you some things that you can
actually make it home to. Um,
so let's get started. Say Hello.
See, I always have to put notes
for myself in these presentations.
It helps me a lot. Um, when I'm doing
this and I say hello and get started.
So we got that done. All right, very
good. All right. So, um, when I was young,
I had no idea that there was such a thing
as a paper engineer or a pop up book
maker, whatever. I was just a kid.
I liked to ride bikes, you know,
my fashion sense was a little
off. Um, but, but I, but I
didn't know and you know,
you guys are really lucky.
Everyone's really lucky to be
able to come here and you know,
be with your parents and uh,
see what they do at work.
It's really important as you
get older, you get to, you,
you get to learn about what things work
and what things you will for you and
what things you might like to do as a job.
Mother,
the things you may not like to do. So,
uh, like growing up, like, you know,
my parents did different things and
you know, I'd go to work with them.
Here is my mother was an aerobic
instructor. There I am in the background.
If you can see really,
and yes,
it was the 80s, you know. Okay.
It's not my fault. All right. Um,
my dad was a dentist. Here I am at
the dentist. I'm helping my dad.
He only let me use that drill
once though. I, yeah. But anyways,
I looked good and strong in scrubs,
but I'm seriously though,
I'm telling a little bit about myself.
Okay. So not for the jokes. Uh,
okay. So I have always
sort of, uh, growing up, I,
my dad was in the navy. We
lived all over the place. Um,
the one thing that I always took with
me was a artwork. So I always drew,
I always made stuff, you know, they're
there. I am in that corner there.
When I was really young, writing
my first book, um, it was a novel.
It took me forever, you
know. Uh, but, um, you know,
I was always making things. I was just
drawing and I was, and, and, and, uh,
creating things with my hands,
uh, because that was the,
that was what could come with me if I
didn't have friends in a new space or,
you know, if I, it was, uh, we had moved,
my artwork always came with me. So I spent
a lot of time by myself making things.
And when, when I was young, you know,
there were no Michael's stores. So, um,
you know, getting supplies to make this
stuff wasn't, wasn't always as easy.
So I was always rummaging through the
garbage or, you know, anything extra,
making things out of box
of cereal boxes, um, uh,
styrofoam from any sort of, uh,
electronic that we ever got. I was always,
you know, buying are grabbing the
boxes and making stuff out of it.
If there was a toy that I,
that didn't exist,
I would make it myself out
of whatever I could. Um,
right there you see a picture
of me with my little sister. Um,
I think I made a little cardboard puppetry
stage and as usual my sister would
destroy it, you know, within a few
seconds she would come over, oh,
this is great rep, you know?
So that was kind of, um,
what it was like, ah,
this is a drawing I did,
I think back in first grade and I've
always had an interest in biology and
zoology and paleontology. I love
dinosaurs. I love, you know,
but I really just loved making artwork
and kind of telling stories with pictures.
As you can see. Also, I was
a little bit of an EGOMANIAC.
My name is really big up in the corner
and I think that's kind of translated
into, you know, myself now. Um,
but, uh, so, uh, it was, uh, it,
but being an artist really wasn't a viable
option, at least when I was younger,
uh, for a career. I,
at the time we didn't have the Google
and we couldn't go online and figure out,
you know, do our research
so easily. You know,
we had to go to those things called
libraries and things and we would go and I
didn't know as much about all the
creative jobs that are out there,
all the ways that you can sort of
channel that creative energy and that,
that talent.
Um,
and so when I went off
from, uh, high school, uh,
I didn't have a lot of motivation.
I mean, really, I, I, uh, to, to,
to find out what I could do. My parents
didn't want me to be a starving artist.
They use that a lot all the time.
We don't want you to be a starving artist,
you know? Um, and uh,
so I went to school for my college
years and I studied biology.
My, my, uh, I actually, uh,
my undergraduate degree is in biological
sciences and it was going to be a
doctor. I studied premed. Uh,
I went to Clemson University
for my undergraduate degree.
Um, and you can see me,
I think I'm up in the corner
there. I'm somewhere. Anyway,
so I went to Clemson the entire time I
was there though while I was studying all
these biology and chemistry
and biochemistry, which is
horrible if you've ever,
biochemistry is the worst. Um, after I,
when I was studying all these different
things, I, I felt something like,
I felt like it wasn't quite right.
I mean,
I was interested in it and
it was pretty good at it.
And actually I got into medical
school, but, but I just,
it wasn't right. So the whole
time I was doing all this science,
I was also doing artwork on the side.
I was always doing sketches.
I was always making these giant
paintings of weird things. Um,
and I wanted to see if there was a way I
could apply that and some of my science
skill, uh, to a job. But I
just didn't know at the time.
So before I went to med school,
like I said,
I got in before I went to school and be
a doctor, which is a long haul, you know,
it's, you, there's a lot that goes into
it. My parents were really pushing for it.
Um, I told him, listen, I need that. I
want a year off before I go to school.
And then went to live in
New York City and um, oop,
that one went before this one. Let's see.
Well, so I lived in New York City. That's,
that's the apartment that we lived in,
down in, um, on canal street. Actually.
We had rats like this big,
I swear to God. Um, it was,
it was a really cool space that
we lived in, but he actually,
we lived over a stereo store,
so like from noon til about
seven at night. The, the,
the vibrations from the stereos downstairs
would move our furniture so they,
everything would shake. Um, and during
that time, and I lived in New York City,
I worked for an organization that
helped find corneas for people who have
trouble with their eyes.
And I worked with a lot of hospitals,
so I was getting an idea of what it was.
It was like to work with sick people.
And I realized I didn't like
working with sick people.
I didn't know it was a good idea for
me to work as a doctor if I didn't like
doing that. It was really hard and it was
really scary. And so while I was here,
you know, I came to that
realization. And then I also,
New York is a really exciting,
creative place. I mean,
there's all kinds of people
doing all kinds of weird jobs.
Things that you would never know existed.
And while I was,
while I was in New York at that time,
and this was about 25 years ago,
um, back back when, you know, the Times
Square was not filled with, you know,
lots of Disneyland like lights and
everything. It was a lot different.
I'm not going to go into that. Um, but uh,
I also was meeting a lot of people who
are doing a lot of different kinds of
jobs and a lot of different
kinds of creative jobs.
And so I ended up going to my
parents and saying, listen,
this is not something I want to do. I
don't want to be a doctor. You know,
I really want to do something creative.
And shockingly, they told me, okay,
you can do that,
but you have to find something
where you're really able
to live because we ain't
paying for your forever.
And so I did my research and I,
I discovered that there is something
called industrial design and that is the
design of products,
all kinds of products,
whether they be tables
or scissors or you know,
like cool Nike shoes or even toys, you
know, that you get like action figures.
I'm a big action figure
collector actually. Um,
I have a huge star wars figure collection,
like 2000 different star wars figures
and I've been collecting since 78 so I
have a lot and I also collect transformers
and you'll see a little bit of that
trickle into the work I do.
Um,
I have a huge transformer collection
now here in New York City.
We don't have a lot of space so I can't
have like a transformers room in my
apartment. I have a
transformer closet, but um,
thank goodness for offsite storage
because that's where the rest of my
collection goes. Anyways, I
studied industrial design at,
let's see if it picture comes up. Pratt
Institute, which is in Brooklyn. And I,
I,
I took a grad,
I did the graduate program
at Pratt Institute study
there for a couple of years.
And while I was there, I, um,
let's see if that other picture comes
up. There it is. It's New York. Well,
I already told you I was in New York.
Um,
while I was there I worked
with a gentleman who, uh,
he needed some help making popups and I
was his intern and I just needed like an
extra job to make some money,
you know, it was okay, you know,
I could cut up and full paper, whatever,
you know, it wasn't a big deal.
I didn't really even think about popups.
In fact,
growing up I only had one pop
up book and this was it. Um,
this dinosaur's obviously and
it was beautiful illustration
and when you open it
up, there's a pop up and it's a
little different than, you know,
from some of the ones that I do.
You know,
I do kind of a little bit
more elaborate ones like this,
but we'll get, get in there. Um,
but I really loved it.
Now this pop up ended up after it was
in my household for a little while,
probably about an hour or so.
It looked like,
like
this
because of one person in the house.
So I really didn't think about popups.
It was never in my mind
anything like that.
That's really, yeah. Yeah. Uh, so papa was
worrying in my mind, but I would help. I,
I, when I was younger and
when I was in Grad School,
I was helping this paper
engineer and you know,
I would cut in full paper and follow
his instructions. And you know,
it was a long time. I worked for him a
couple of years just doing this. And, and,
and when I got to school,
I realized that maybe this is a,
maybe this is something I can
do. And so there was a lot. So,
so for quite a few years I apprenticed
and what that really means is I worked
and I would help him with his work.
And it wasn't always the
stuff I wanted to do. In fact,
the designs I didn't always like,
even though he did really beautiful work,
like,
um, I worked with Robert Buddha, um,
for many years and he
does a lot of very white,
beautiful structural popups and stuff.
We worked on things for like the Moma and,
and all kinds. And I'm an other
publishers. I learned a lot from,
from just learning how
structurally how this stuff,
but it wasn't always this stuff
that I wanted to do myself.
But that's really important in the
beginning when you're learning something,
sometimes you've got to do the work and
it isn't always exactly what you want to
do,
but it helps you learn.
So after years of learning all these
different principles and learning all this
stuff, how to make popups, I was, I
got to start doing my own books. Um,
some of the, the first two books
I did were, weren't like these,
they were these really weird books,
the pop up book of Phobias and
the public will get nightmares.
They were these bizarre books. I never
even thought they'd actually come out. Um,
but, but actually the phobia book was
really popular, especially with, um,
with therapists in the city.
Then I was able to start making books that
I really, really was about. Um, I had,
uh, I, my first New York Times bestseller
was a pop up book of butterflies.
And after that we were able to create a
series about prehistoric animals cause I
love paleontology.
First was this dinosaur book and
called Encyclopedia Pre Historica.
And this has been translated now into
about 25 different languages around the
world. And doing this project, you know,
it says I collaborate on these books,
I collaborated Roberts to Buddha.
He would just sort of oversee things,
but I would,
I would do the writing,
the artwork and the right
and the engineering. So all,
all parts of making a pop up book,
we made three in this series.
And when you make,
when you're just starting out and you're
making these big books, you learn a lot.
Boy, you learn a lot, but
you make a lot of mistakes.
And each book I look at it and I
see a lot of mistakes. In fact,
I can't always enjoy my books when they're
finished because all I do is go, Oh,
you could've done that better.
Oh, that wasn't that good.
But a lot of other people don't know
that. So, um, you know, Aye, I, yes,
I go to a therapist
about this sort of stuff.
So I did this series and then
let's see what else we got.
I've done a lot of books about,
you know,
a classic stories and fairy tales
like Cinderella and the jungle book,
which was really awesome. I love that.
That one, I did a series about mythology.
So I love learning about like things like
mythology and history and science and,
and um, I like, I kind of have one of
those mines where I'm obsessive surprise.
Um, like I, I get obsessive
about this subject, so when
I want to learn something,
I just don't want to learn a little.
I got to learn a lot.
And what happens though,
when you do that,
especially when you're
creating books like this,
you have only so much space in
this, in this, uh, biological
computer in your head.
And so when I learned something else,
it kind of pushes the old stuff
out and the new stuff goes in.
So I learned stuff and then,
you know, it pushes all stuff.
So thank God I still know how to
walk and talk because you know,
like I've learned so much about
all these different subjects.
So this is mythology, this series,
the gods in here, a book is,
that's actually pretty cool.
There's a lot of fun to do.
I did a book with Maurice
Sendak at one point.
Maurice Sendak did where
the wild things are.
This pop up book was called
Mommy and it was about it.
It barely had any words in it,
but it was about a baby who
went into a mad scientist lab.
And of course in in more
racist world, the baby, uh,
defeats all the monsters in funny ways,
like pulling down their pants and doing
fun stuff like that. Which of course,
I mean it makes total sense. I also,
like I said, really loves star wars. Now,
I'm an old school star wars fan.
And so I did the first book for the 30th
anniversary of the original star wars
trilogy. And that's awesome. This
year is the 40th anniversary.
So that book is 10 years old. Um,
it was incredible. It was the,
it was a huge dream come true. It was a
dream and it was a nightmare, you know,
making it so I'm so obsessive that I
had to get everything just right that I
actually put myself in that
book as a character. Um,
so it was fun to be able to do that
and put some of my friends, in fact,
a lot of times and some of them in my
books, I do put family and friends,
even pets, um, that I used to have.
In fact in my Cinderella book,
my pet rabbits from when I was a kid
are following Cinderella throughout the
book. Uh, because, um,
everyone wants to learn about Lucy
Bernadine and fuzzball my pet rabbits from
when I was,
when these young,
I also do the second star wars book and
I'll probably do a third star wars book
once we're finished with the new trilogy.
I can't wait.
I love comic books.
Uh,
and especially at DC comics I
did to a superhero books so far,
but there may be another big
marvel one coming in the future.
I actually got to work with six different
comic book artists for this book.
It was awesome to be able to create
it and actually has a light up. Um,
some of my books have light up
parts and then I what they call my,
my type of a work paper engineering,
they call it low tech engineering
cause I'm only working with one type of
material paper. But sometimes I
use other things like electronics.
So in this book and in the Star Wars book,
there are electronics,
like as a matter of fact,
like at the end of the star wars book,
here's Darth Vader now
and it's at the top,
there are two working lights and now
you can't tell what the lights in here,
but that lightsaber that Luke has lights
up. And then on the opposite side,
the Darth Vader windows.
So there's actually wires that
go in underneath the page.
I wished the lights weren't so bright,
but you would be able to see that better.
But anyways, it's been cool to be
able to create things like that.
And then this one has a bat signal that
lights up. It's super cool. Um, yes,
I'm a Brownie. I totally made
a pony book. It was awesome.
And I can't wait for the big movie. What's
cool about working with Milo ponies?
I in this book, I actually got
to make myself a pony. Um, uh,
my pony name is professor of paper
scraps and I dare you to find me in this,
in this book. I'm somewhere in one of
the backgrounds. So it was really cool.
I love the, I, my sister loved my
little pony when we were young,
but the new pony show is awesome and I
was forced to watch all of them and it
was great. It was great. I love
it. It was really fun. I did.
Sometimes I try to do books
where they aren't just a book.
There's something else.
This book was for the game of
Thrones and it not only becomes,
it's not only a popup book about all the
different places in the game of Thrones,
in Westeros and everything,
it also becomes a giant map.
It's about as big as a table. So
you can enjoy it both ways. Um,
some people say like,
it's important to think outside the box.
I like to say it's important to
think outside the book. And I'm,
so there are a lot more projects that are
coming up that we're trying to stretch
the boundaries of what a pop up book can
be or just what a book can be and how
it can be interactive.
Um, I also like to express
my feminine side and I, uh,
Eh, I am big into princesses. Okay.
So, um, and I'm cool with that.
I'm cool with that. All right, so I've
done, um, to Disney princess books.
One was of course frozen
because let me tell you,
when Disney calls you up and they say,
would you like to do a fro?
You don't even let them finish the
word you say. Yes, yes, I will. Um,
I worked on the frozen book. I let me
tell you, I didn't stop singing that song.
I like to hear it in my sleep
and I let it go. You know,
I would hear it all the time,
but it was, it was great.
It was really fun to work on.
And I also worked on a Disney princess
book cause I love a classic animation.
Um, and so many of those
Disney princess movies,
especially things like Cinderella and uh,
well I was,
I'm my personal favorite is
a little mermaid. Um, those,
those movies like really transformed
the artists that I am today.
So they were really big influences.
And so do you to work on that
and to make like Cinderella,
super cool that Cinderella actually,
she transforms. So she's like, Oh,
I'm all sad, Cinderella. And then you
pull the bottom of her skirt thing.
You don't pull your skirt,
but there's a little tab on the bottom
and it transforms into like Super Fab,
a Cinderella. So it was really
cool. That was a hard pop to design.
Let's see
here we go
here.
Oh, oh. Well of course, in
one of my most recent books,
something I know that everyone
here at Google loves Lego.
So a couple of years ago the Lego
folks came to me and they said,
would you want to do a Lego?
And I didn't even let them finish that
sentence either. Um, yes, totally.
I grew up building with Lego.
Uh, but back when I was young,
we didn't have all the cool
sets that you guys have now.
We just had like whatever, six colors
and I think we had wheels maybe.
Um, but it was, we never,
when you would make something,
it never looked like one object. It
always just kind of look like, you know,
a bunch of different
bricks stuck together.
Whereas now you have so many
different pieces. It's, I actually,
when I was researching this book,
I tried to get the Lego people to tell
me a number of all the different pieces
that they've ever made,
you know, not color,
but then the types of pieces and
they couldn't even give it to me.
There's so many different pieces.
They don't even have a number for that.
So when I worked on this
book, I actually, uh,
went to the Lego headquarters
in Billund in Denmark.
I went to their special
like design headquarters,
which is this big white
like sort of vague,
I think they call it the
white box or something.
And I can't tell you what was
in there, but it was awesome.
It was awesome. And um,
it's really like,
there's such artists that work there.
It's incredible how they figure out
how to make these beautiful things with
these little plastic brick. It's,
it's, it's, it's an, it's incredible.
So working on this book, my research was
really tough. I mean they had to, like,
they sent me like 200 different Lego
sets and I, you know, built Legos.
It was really hard. Yeah. Actually, I
got a couple of interns to help me. Um,
because it takes a while. I mean, I
know that some of the parents here know,
like when you get those, you know, you
get those sets, like it takes a while,
especially when they're those big ones.
So we built everything and then
we made the uh, then, you know,
made the pops and then made the artwork.
Here's a little sample of what's inside,
like a pop up.
And I did the writing, the popups
and the art in this. Um, yeah,
and there are, there are cool
pops in this, that transform,
this one transforms into
three different things.
And then there's tons of mini figures
and all kinds of cool things. That's my,
that's my assistant there.
Works in Ninjago too. Um,
and it has this huge pop in it that is
super tall. It's this big tall tower. Uh,
pops. Actually we're going to have
a giveaway of some books later on.
So think in your mind about like some,
some cool lego facts,
just thinking in your head and
we'll get back to that later on.
So in Fra see notes, know, tell Tom.
Okay, so his is how I do what I do.
All right. When I work in my office
down in the West Village, um,
all I do is I stick paper in the
machine and Papa books come out.
That's how I do it. All right,
I'm ready. I'll see you later. No,
actually that's not what I do. Don't you
love my angry face in that picture too?
I was like [inaudible]
that's not how it's done.
It's actually a really long process.
Making a pop up book sometimes takes
from like four to six months and uh, to,
to make a whole book from
the beginning to the end.
And then most of that work has to be
done about eight months before it's
actually on the shelves.
Because after I make one book,
there has to be a whole group of people
that helped me make thousands more.
So here's how it's done
first. Do you know,
of course, uh, I have to get ideas
for things. I have to get inspiration.
I look all around me.
I look at the world everywhere and try
to take inspiration from anything I can
see. Or you know, you're lucky
that you guys are in New York.
There's so much here and I think
most of the pictures that are here,
I took in New York. Um, there's so much,
there's so much to see and,
but I think that you can be
anywhere and be inspired by things.
So I take inspiration from,
from everywhere and um,
sometimes you can see the way that some
things built and that might inspire you
to make something really
cool in a pop up book.
So the tools I use making popups of
course, after I've written the story,
let's see.
Okay, paper. Yeah, I use a lot of card
stock. I usually work in white card stock.
This is it right here. You can get it.
It's a little heavier than regular paper.
You can get it like the
office stores and everything.
And the reason why I use it in white
is first I want to figure out what the
structure is and then I worry about
coloring it or drawing on it or whatever.
So usually in the beginning I
just work in white paper. Um,
I of course use a tape.
I use different kinds of tape.
I you said lots of scissors,
glue,
[inaudible] glue and exacto knife.
The exacto knife I use to make really
intricate cuts and I need lots of bandaids
cause I don't just make cuts on the
paper. I yes, I like Hello Kitty.
Okay,
let's see.
So at the beginning, this is kind
of what the rough pop up looks like.
I may have an idea for what is going to
happen on that popup page. Just words.
I will never like draw a picture of
what I'm going to make. I usually, uh,
I just have a word of what might happen.
So I just thought to myself,
I wanted to have a pop up that
uh, the dinosaur bit, the reader.
I thought that'd be really fun because
if you were going to experience a t rex,
like that would be the coolest way to,
well,
I mean you wouldn't
really want to be eaten,
but it would be cool if
they kind of came at you.
So this is the first version and
I'll take it apart very carefully.
Trace the pieces in the computer using
Adobe illustrator and I'll you make what
are called dye lines and these guidelines
are going to be used later on for when
they manufacture this
thousands of times over.
So I will remake the pop up sometimes
up to 10 times or even 20 times,
um, to make sure that it works just right
when you can see there's even notes on
that and everything and that's
what it looks like in the final.
Now one of the things that I
also make the artwork as well,
and I'll show you how I do that as a,
also I do a style of artwork
called cut paper collage.
So I'm cutting up paper to make the pops.
I thought it'd be cool to also cut
up paper to make the artwork as well.
Oh, in the beginning, this is
where the pop up looks like.
This is just this get
the movement right now.
I actually went and studied a horse and
how it moved and this was going to be a
book. This book never actually came
out. Oh, well anyways. Um, why don't,
why don't you buy for you? Uh, it wasn't
that exciting. I swear. I swear it's not.
So this is, um, an early prototype that
actually had sketches on it. This is,
this is something that's called,
um, uh, white dummy and it,
it goes to the,
my editor now the editor works at a
publisher and she kind of corrects all my
work.
She kind of imagine it's like your
teacher and she actually goes through and
marks things that are,
that are written wrong or she may have
been mark some of the pops and say,
I don't think that this is a
good thing that you should do,
should do something else. So she'll, um,
and just like a teacher or
she marks it in red, you know,
so it's great when you get that back.
But usually I don't get,
I do okay with my editors and usually
they're, they're on the same. Um, they,
they're on the same page. So this bigger,
uh, I didn't mean to do that. I'm sorry.
Um, as me, when we're making
popups and this is just, you know,
show you some of the details that
growing up go into making it,
this is an early version
of the Darth Vader pop.
This was a really tough
pop up to make because, um,
there's two portions of Darth Vader's
helmet. There's a, well, there's actually,
there's, there's three, there's,
I don't want to get into it,
I'm not going to get into it,
but there's anyways, what,
what happens with this
is actually you could,
I wanted the reader to be able to see
Anna can for a couple of seconds before
the mass closed up over and when
the popup open. So you can actually,
if you look as it's opening, it's
really important. Like the time,
you can see him for a second and
then it closes over his face.
Cause because everyone makes,
everyone notices those little things.
So this took me a long time to be,
and I had to actually engineer the front
part of his face separately than the
back and then put them together.
So it took a lot,
a lot of time and a lot of prototypes
to get it. You even look like this.
So you see,
I've kind of sculpted it and white first
and then their sketches around it and
then, and then, and then,
oh, that's the wrong thing. And then,
then that's the final color version.
When I was doing this book I actually,
which was awesome. I got, you know,
I do get some perks when I work with
some of these, uh, different, uh,
companies and things.
I got to go to this star wars archives.
So this was the Lucas film
archives in Marin County.
This was actually at the Skywalker ranch.
They don't even let people
go here anymore. So I,
I got in there at the right time.
Um,
and they had all the
masks from the old movies.
Those are actual stunt light
sabers. That's my, my editor and I,
and we're getting ready to fight about
something and those are stunt library
lightsabers from him.
And the matte painting in
the back is actually used
from the empire strikes back.
Um,
so I am like,
I couldn't stop smiling after this was
so much fun to go see and you know,
did I need to go? I remember
when my editor says, Oh,
do you think you're going to need to go
to the Lucas archives to look at things
now I know. Let me do it. At the time
I owned hundreds of star wars books,
I had every movie, you know, I have
tons. I knew everything about it.
Of course it was like, yes, I
think, I think I should probably go.
So I was able to go.
It was,
it was an awesome experience and I've
had a lot of Nice experiences like that.
Like the big fan in me gets
to go do these cool things.
This is me working in my student,
not this fast. I, this is, yeah,
this is me working in the studio probably
over a few hours and I'm designing a
pop up and as you can
see it's just by hand.
There's no computer program.
The computer program,
it comes in when I actually take the pop
apart and trace it now after I've made
all those dye lines,
all those lines that are tracings of
pieces I may go in and make artwork
sometimes isn't the computers,
sometimes it's by hand and I put the
artwork and those dialogues together
rebuild the pop up again and
again to make sure it works.
And that is how a popup was made.
This was for the transformers pop up book.
Like I said, I love transformers
that um, that was just a,
a quick pop up, how to
make, um, for that book.
That was an incredible book to do as well.
I have a lot of dream projects that
come true. People always ask me,
you must not have any more dreams laugh.
I be like, let me tell you. I've got lots.
There's always something else that I
wanted to do. I have a lot of dreams. Um,
this is just a prototype of what the
book looks like before it was in color.
And um, sometimes I do the artwork and
sometimes other people do the art work.
Like I said, I worked with
Maurice Sendak once. Um,
and then for this book I
actually worked with, um,
a great transformer artist name
Ameliana Ameliana no, centrally.
He lives in Italy. I actually never got
to see him the whole time we worked over,
you know, we just send things back and
forth to each other over the Internet.
And I would draw the sort of sketch and
what he should draw and made all kinds
of notes about what, where and
where, what it should look like.
And then he would make the art and then
I would put that with those dieline
pieces.
So you can see like sometimes for one
pop up there might be like 30 different
pieces that work in tandem.
All these different levers and,
and different mech
mechanics working together.
Or there may be other times
when I make the artwork myself,
now I think about making
a pop up. Um, okay,
so there's three different stages and
making pop up. You have to have the,
you have the writing done,
you know,
and the reason we'd ever research and
writing, um, that's like a cake. You know,
when you're making cake,
that's the recipe or you got to have that.
The next step is the actual cake.
You know,
you're actually going to
bake something. So, um,
the next step is actually making the cake.
And then the artwork is the
frosting to me. I love frosting. Um,
so making color artwork.
Now I said I use,
I make a style called a cut paper
collage and I actually by hand, uh,
make all these different types of art.
Sometimes it's digital,
but usually it's by hand. I, I take all
these papers that I've made in my studio,
all these different textures. I have a
huge rack of different new papers that,
that we're constantly using. And I will,
uh, I will show you how a little bit,
how it's done.
First I'll draw a picture.
I'm just very quickly,
uh,
it's usually tighten up a sketch
and then I'll use that sketch as my,
as my,
I'm sort of map and I'll cut out sections
of different colored paper with my
exacto knife.
Okay.
I'll lay it in the place using my sketch
sort of as a guide and I printed on a
clear piece of plastic.
Um,
then I'll glue in the different
pieces of colored paper.
And the glue I use is very similar
to Elmers glue, White Glue.
And then that's what the
final thing will look like.
And it's a very small piece of artwork,
but it may have 20 different little pieces
of paper all glued together. Make one.
Sometimes some of my larger
pieces, um, may have, uh, you know,
hundreds of pieces of
paper glued together.
When I make the artwork for the pop
up pieces, it's a little different.
I have to make the artwork
like all splat it out and like,
it's almost looks like a, it's like pop
up road kill, you know, like they're,
they're offside. There's pieces here and
there. Um, and, and after so many years,
I figured out where each piece needs to
be or what needs to be on what's piece,
cause sometimes the head isn't
necessarily connected to the body. So, um,
I figured it out after a long time.
But you know,
they're the one thing I don't
really say, do you guys, uh,
it didn't say that earlier was that there
are a lot of mistakes along the way.
I don't just start out and
have the perfect idea first.
And it all looks great for
every wow pop up that you see.
There's a lot of not so
wows that get thrown out.
And that's the way I figure things
out. You know, I, I sort of,
I will make something and see if
it's something I like. If it's not,
then I try something different and that's,
you know,
hopefully you guys can get from this.
It doesn't come out perfect and it's
okay because we're supposed to learn from
our mistakes and I've made saw many
of them you wouldn't even know.
And it's okay to do that cause that's
how we get better. Well, so, okay.
So I've made one pop up,
I've made all the art,
I've made all the pops and I may
all the words. Now what do I do?
So I send all that and I send one
pop up book that I made by hand to a
manufacturer and the manufacturer,
they're actually pop pop up
books or hand manufactured.
Once I make one pop up book, um, I uh,
the next step is sending all
that information to uh, uh,
a printer and a hand assembly,
a manufacturer. And um, uh,
so that's all sent. Usually
the work is done overseas. Um,
and I've worked with a lot of
these manufacturers for years,
so they understand how to
put together popups. In fact,
they're more of experts than assembling
popups then than I could ever be.
And they tell me things, this
doesn't work. This will work.
Here's some ideas about things.
So what they'll do is they'll break down
the book and into different groups and
one group will make
just one page of a book.
And I'm so each person they'll remake,
we used person,
we'll make one section of, so
for example, if this ad ad here,
one person will assemble this leg and
handed off to the next person and there
will be a large group that just works
on this page and they'll make thousands.
Sometimes it can make up, they're like
15,000 a week. Um, they're really hand,
they're really incredibly
skilled hand laborers and they,
they oftentimes come up with ideas that
are way better than what I come up with.
So I work the entire time during that
production, which is usually, like I said,
about eight months before in a book,
hits the shelves.
So they'll send me prototypes and then
once they actually start building the
books, they can, you know,
make up to 15,000 a week.
They'll package them up, um,
after they've made each spread,
they'll, they'll glue them together.
Then the little cover on it though,
I'm clamp them, let them dry,
and then they will get shipped
off in boxes all over the world.
So it's kind of goes from my hands
creating the original book to the
manufacturer's hands, to your hands
in the, in, um, in the bookstores.
So it's really,
it's really too cool.
But there are a lot of products that we
don't realize are made by hand when they
are. There isn't like some giant machine
that will do all this work for us.
You know, there's some really
intricate things that we, um,
that we have and that we buy and
there are hands that go into it.
So now I'm going to show you,
now that I've talked about myself enough,
uh,
we're going to make a pop right here and
I'm going to show you some basics and,
um,
but I,
but I'm going to need an idea
for what I should make. Now,
last time someone came up
with a really crazy idea and,
um, I've, I did it of course, but, uh,
it was something, it was pretty
funny. So a, anyone got an idea?
You want to raise your hand and
I'll take, let's see. Let's see.
Okay. Yes, plants.
Okay. That works well. I like this green.
So I'm gonna use that for
the actual plants, I think.
So what I'm going to start
with is just this card stock.
I'm going to fold it in half.
Okay.
Oh, I've already got an idea. Oh, oh, oh,
oh yeah. So, okay, we're
gonna start off. This is,
we took a piece of paper and we folded in
half just like that. All right. And um,
just for the sake of being
able to see it on video,
I'm going to make a line down the
center so it's a little easier to see.
So you see that center line we're going
to, when we make some of our pieces,
we're going to align it.
We're gonna line up the folds on things
cause that's a lot of pop up people.
Do they like line up different folds
to make sure things work right?
So one of the things,
I'm going to make something called a
beef fold and the Vif old is actually,
well, it's shaped like a v
and most of the popups in,
in most of my books use some form of
Vif fold. Um, that's not a good one.
Okay, see this, see this
big dinosaur, see, see this,
this piece underneath his body here
that,
and it's sort of like triangular and v.
So that's a v and you
can see that it moves.
It actually is forcing all
these pieces to move up.
So a vehicle moves.
And so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
Make Two v folds and I'm gonna Make Two v
folds that that are,
they're both right angles,
right angles are 90 degree
angles, right? Um, correct.
I mean. Correct. Uh, so let's
see here. I'm to take a piece of,
I'm going to take a different piece
would say gray so that you can see these
pieces. And what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to make, first,
I'm going to make a square,
a small square out of paper,
and then I'm going to make two
triangles from that square.
Yeah.
And you say, Matthew, how can
that be done? I just don't
know. Well, okay, so right.
I just folded the rectangle
right now. Correct. I mean,
because if I say right angle,
it's, it's very confusing.
So then I'm going to fold
this triangle down like this
and
I'll be able to see,
I cut it along the edge like that.
Okay.
And like,
uh,
then we have a square cause this side,
this side, this side and this side.
It's pretty close.
And we need two triangles that are,
oh, if I cut this down the middle,
I get two triangles that are equal.
Right? We're learning geometry to today.
Good thing you're not in school. You
know, it's funny. People say all the time,
you must have been really good at
geometry. And I don't remember.
I don't think I w I think I, no, I
wasn't. I was not a great math student.
Um, I did okay. But Calculus,
Oh man, did that kill me?
Um,
so there we have two triangles and what
we're going to do is fold them in half
and we're going to make two v folds.
There's one,
yeah.
And the fold where theV is, is going
to be down here. Here's the second one.
And we're going to tape these onto our
base. And you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to make a line on that full
just so we know so you can see it better.
Cause I last time we
couldn't see it as well.
Okay,
sure.
It's really open isn't it?
Yeah cause now I've given you a
lot of cleavage today. All right,
so here are Our v folds and we're going
to have them actually when we glue them
onto this onto the page, we're going to
have them point to the points touching.
So we're going to,
we're going to make sure that that center
line on the top V is lined up with the
main base. Page one.
We're going to do the same
on the bottom. Just like
that kind of looks like an
hourglass a little bit. Right.
And I'm gonna use some white
tape if I have it. Yes.
So I use this tape,
it's very similar to
masking tape in my studio.
It's art artists tape and we're going to,
we're going to tape along
the v because it's a v fold
and there is one.
Okay.
Lined up just like that.
And I always make sure that I put,
I make sure that the tape
is really secure on there.
So now we can see when it moves.
See there is one V,
Huh.
Now we want another view,
but it's going to go the other way.
Actually I'm going to move
it more towards the middle.
That's the other thing.
You can't be afraid.
Don't be afraid when
you're making these popups.
Don't be afraid to pick up the
pieces and move them around.
If you don't like the way they are
can always change,
you know, always make, you
know, remake and fix your
mistakes. I'm just, by the way,
I also, uh, have a, uh, I'm supposed to
remember like all my social media stuff,
so I'm cause I'm not real good at it.
So I have a youtube page where you
can make your own pops. Um, uh,
if you look up Matthew Reinhardt, it's
called a law. Um, let's make it pop.
And I have different crafts.
I'm trying to do them every week.
So if I miss a week, please
don't get mad at me. Um, but, uh,
there's always different things. In
fact, tomorrow is National Superhero Day,
so wear your Cape. Okay. Um, anyways,
tomorrow is national spirit and there's
a pop up super hero card that we made
for a, and I think it went up today so
you can make your own, um, superior.
So there's One v and I'm going to
attach the second V. I know a plant,
I'm making the plant.
Um,
I'm going to just attach this
and then what we're going to do once we
have these two V's working in opposite
directions, then we're going
to make something. It's a,
it's a mechanism or I'm going to
show you they are the two. All right?
And they look, they're going in
different directions. One's going up,
one's going down.
What's cool about this is one side,
like this lower triangle here,
if we attach something to the edge
here on the opposite side, on the top,
on that same edge, so on
opposite sides. So let's see,
I'm looking at myself on there and there.
So if we had make a bridge going across,
if we make a bridge going,
I was trying to watch myself in this thing
and I was like, wait, what's going on?
If we make a bridge going
across what we'll actually,
we'll be able to connect the two and
we'll make a pop up that kind of expands
and twists.
So it's really cool.
So the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to kind of make a little bit
thinner, longer sort of bridge piece.
And I'm going to mark with another color,
the the edges that we're going to connect.
Okay.
You guys see that there to
there and then I'm going to see,
did I make,
I didn't make that long enough.
If you saw my studio, it is a wreck. I
mean there's, there's paper everywhere.
Sometimes I'll come out of my office
after a long day and I'll just have paper
all over. I won't even realize
it. And you know, you know,
people are like y'all get home and,
and you know it's like there's something
on your shirt and it's like the shoes,
you know, piece of piece of
paper or half of a pop up.
Like nobody told me this on the way out.
Okay,
so it's going to go across.
The only thing that is not going to work
is we need to snip off this little bit
and this little bit.
So I'm just gonna use my marker
and
roughly get align.
So there you can see where I'm
supposed to cut it and want to snip,
snip using my tape. And we're going to
attach this.
And what's cool at with this is
we're going to do a part
where it makes sense. Okay.
So now we are going to
attach it from under here.
We'll have a tape go up.
Like I said,
this pop up is called a twister
because it twists. Oh, that's a cool.
The reminder. Matthew, please shut
up soon. All right, here we go.
All right, so now it's attached
from here. All the way across.
There's a bridge and when we close it,
see how it sort of Boeing,
oop, we don't want that.
I mean, come on man. I'm
just gonna make sure it's attached,
right?
And that you have your tape on
there pretty hard. All right,
so we're going to fold it and it's
going to sort of arc like that.
And what's going to happen is
you're going to fold it and it will,
you are going to find,
find the fold.
So you're going to kind of press
down on your pop and smash a little.
So now, now, uh, I'm a very
sensitive artist. Okay.
So when I opened this,
I needed like positive reinforcement.
So I need you to say like,
Ooh,
like be really surprised and excited when
you see it. Okay. Let me make sure. Okay.
All right. Thank God. Thank God.
Wow, that's really
exciting. Wow. All right.
But this is the start of what we
can start building on top of this.
So let's see, what can we do?
You're going to make a plant, right?
So first we need some leaves,
right?
And every surface that's here,
it has potential to become
a part of the pop up.
So I'm going to use double stick
tape. Now. Usually I use glue,
but because you know I don't
have a lot of time. There we go.
So there's a leaf and another leaf.
So you guys having fun today,
you learn a lot about,
about what your mom and dad's and
everyone else, all your parents do.
Is it boring? No. Okay, good. I
didn't think it'd be boring here.
Every time I pass by here. So I live in
New York. I live actually in Chelsea.
I'm a few blocks from here.
Every time I pass by Google Belding
I always think to myself, God,
I want a job there.
Um,
because everyone looks like they're so
like having fun and smart and you know,
here I am on my bike and I'm, you know,
covered with paper and sad and pathetic.
So, um, so there's the start of my plant.
Maybe I'll put some leaves here,
but whatever you're doing
here seems exciting.
And so it's cool to be able to get
an idea of what people do. Okay.
I'm starting to get more here.
It's still,
and I'm just adding pieces of paper.
Let's see.
And it doesn't look as
pretty in the beginning.
Sometimes it's just
getting those shapes right.
Let's see. Okay. I don't
want to get a little better.
I mean they wouldn't be hiring me for the,
uh,
the Google doodles anytime soon
on that one. Um, let's see.
We also maybe, you know, most plants
kind of need a little pot to go in,
so we'll cut a little shape down here.
Oh, by the way, should we do that
now while I finish this up? Um,
we are going to give away. How
many books do we have for, um,
we have four books to give away. Um,
now, I'm sorry, we don't have a lot more.
Um, but that's all we had
to give away for today. Um,
you can find my books anywhere.
Like any bookstore,
you can find it online and
Amazon, all those places. Um, uh,
even places like toys r us and
things like that. So, you know,
like there are everywhere. Um, I,
like I said, I have a youtube channel.
You can find me on
Facebook. Uh, there's a, um,
Matthew rock pop up books
by Matthew Reinhardt. Um,
so I'm all over the place and
we're going to do a quick,
we're going to have people,
if you have a Lego fact,
I want you to raise your
hand and Lauren will pick.
Now you have to tell us what your
fact is and then you get a book. Um,
so Lauren,
why don't you start going ahead and
I'll finish up my pop up while you start
doing that.
Yeah.
Yep.
And you have to speak up so we
can hear you. That's part of it.
You have to end. You can't
make it up. All Right,
nice.
83. That's right. Get the
man a book. Congratulations.
And I will sign your book at the end,
um, after we're finished. If you'd like.
Oh, the fact was it's been around
how many years? 80, 83 years.
Okay.
Go for it.
Oh yeah, that sounds
right. That sounds good.
Awesome.
Congratulations.
Oh, that's right. And it's
actually in my lego pop.
You get to see that the
evolution of many fingers.
How many living now do you guys have?
Lots of Lego mini figures. Yeah.
It's kind of insane
how many there are now.
Okay.
I'm still working on this,
right?
Yeah.
What's you, what Lego's
headquarters really?
I mean, yes. I mean, yes. I
think you said something about
quarters. I was like, what?
Headquarters? Yes, of course. I was there.
Totally. Yeah. I'm sorry. I'm out of it,
you guys. All right. So
awesome. Congratulations
everybody who wanted the book.
And like I said, I
will. I will definitely.
So wait, I'm not quite done. Um, so she
said you wanted to plant, but you know,
like plants aren't always most
active, you know, things. Of course,
the first thing she said, or
for the first, when she first
said it, I thought, well,
I'll make a plant, but I'm gonna make
'em this plant into a Venus fly trap.
Because, let's see, I've lost some of my,
let's see if I put the neck up here.
Oh yeah,
totally,
totally.
I had a friend who was in one of those
musicals and he wasn't so good. It was a,
it was a community theater and I had
to go see him singing. He was Seymour.
It wasn't so good at it. Um, so let's see
if that works. Does that going to work?
It's going gonna now. Like, like I said,
sometimes we don't get everything right,
so you got to keep trying.
Here we go.
And I lost a leaf in there.
It's hard to do it on the fly.
Let's see if that works. There we go. Now
it sticks out. I cheated a little bit,
but there we go. Oh, we lost the link.
Not Bad.
Could use a little bit more work.
If I had more time,
I'd be able to make something cooler.
But anyways,
thank you so much for having me. You
guys were awesome and, um, you're,
I want to make any pop ups go online
and, uh, have a good day today.
Hi.
All.